اصلا الادعاء العام الالمانيه اليوم اوامر
اعتقال بحق 25 فردا يجتبه في انتمائهم الى
مجموعه مواطني الرايخ وقالت متحدثه باسم
الادعاء العام في كاسترو ان السلطات سنه
الحمله في 11 ولايه المانيه لم يتم
الاعلان بعد عن مزيد من التفاصيل يذكر ان
اعضاء مجموعه مواطنين الرايخ لا يعترفون
بالدوله الالمانيه الحديثه التي تاسست بعد
انهيار النازيه ولا بقوانينها ويمتنعون عن
دفع ضرائب ومخصصات اجتماعيه ويصرون على ان
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه لا تزال قائمه
معنى الان من برلين مراسلنا عيسى طيبي
عيسى اذا تطور لافت
وهذا الاعلان من جانب وزير العدل ماذا في
التفاصيل تفضل
الالماني هذه المجموعه كانت تخطط
لهجوم مسلح على مؤسسات الدوله
[موسيقى]
قال بان احد عشر ولايه من بين ال 16
جمهوريه الايرانيه الالمانيه شهدت هذه
الحمله وبمعنى اخر ان الشرطه القيراليه
مكتب مكافحه الجريمه الاتحاد وهو النسخه
الاربعاء الالمانيه الامريكيه في المانيا
وكل هذه القوه اشتركت في هذه العمليه عن
الاختبارات التاريخيه تسمى
والاستخباراتيه شاركت في هذه العمليه التي
قالت اغلب الولايات تتحدث عن احد عشر
ولايه ال ال ال ال ال ال
التكتل الكبير القاعده الحاضنه الكبرى
لحركه مواطن الرايخ هي ولايه البفاريا
للمفارقه ولايه البخاري الغنيه وهي اغنى
ولايه بعد كاليفورنيا في العالم هي هي
القاعده قاعده
مواطنيه الرايه بخلاف بقينا الحركه
المعروفه المتطرفه التي تتخذ من شرق
المانيا الفقير قاعده لها هذا لذلك اليوم
يمكن الان نلاحظ ان هذا التغير في في في
في في في شعب والمجموعات الجميله المتطرف
بقضيه النازيه ايضا لا تتوقف على المناطق
الخطيره وعلى الشارقه التقليدي الالماني
وانما ايضا في الجنوب وفي الشمال ونتحدث
ايضا عن الغربه
الولايات الغربيه موجوده ضمن قائمه
الاعتداء
هذه اللحظه لكن هناك تاكيدات من مصالح
الامن بان هذه العمليه لن تتوقف عند هذا
الرقم بسبب ما اشار اليه وزير العدل بان
المعطيات التي لدى الاجهزه الامنيه تقول
بان هناك احتمال هجوم مسلح على الهيئات
الدستوريه الالمانيه وبذلك نتوقع ان تكون
الحصيله اكثر من ذلك وخصوصا ان النائب
العام
الهجري هو الذي يشرف على هذه العمليه او
اعظم
الضوء الاخضر القانون هذه العمليه للتذكير
ايضا لان هذه الحركه قامت باول عمليه
جنائيه في المانيا في اكتوبر عام
2016 عندما كانت همم من الوحده الخاصه
الامنيه الالمانيه ومن يومها بدا الحديث
وكشف اللثام عن الجيش السري الذي تحاول
الذي الرمل ثم تقول مصادر انه تاسس لكن
العمل جاري على تاسيسه الى غايه عمل 2018
قالت هيئه حمايه الدستور لاستخبارات
الداخليه الالمانيه بان قوامها في
الولايات الجنوبيه نحو سته عشر الف من ضمن
لكن الرقم الان بعد هذه السنوات تضاعف
لاسباب متعدده خصوصا ااه
النيل في عمومي المانيا خصوصا بعد الموجه
اللاجئين وغيرها من القضايا التي ترتبت
والتي تداعت ايضا في اشتراكات همم
الشارقه والغرب او حتى الجنوب الالماني
نعم نعم
الالماني في عام 2016 اكتوبر عام 2016 ومن
ذلك الوقت والاستخبارات الالمانيه فتحت
اعينها صح التعبير على هذا التنظيم ولكن
هذا على ما يبدو لم يمنعه من ان يتكاثر
عددا وحتى ان يتسلح بطريقه كبيره الحديث
عن اسلحه كبيره تتوفر لهذا التنظيم
والحديث عن جيش سري الى اي حد فعلا كانت
هناك متابعه حثيثه خلال السنوات الماضيه
منذ عام 2016 لهذا التنظيم
حدود التنظيم همم
كما قلت في في مقدمه الحديث بانه هو هو
جزء متسلسل في نسيج اليمين المتطرف
بان المنتمين لهم والمتعاطفين له
والمنظرين له
يتواجدون في كل مكان وفي مختلف الاجهزه
الامنيه هناك الوحده الاقوى وحده في الجيش
الالماني
الخاصه تم حلها بالكامل بسبب وجود
قاعده من اليمنيين الذيين في اركانها تطور
ان الوحده الوحده النخبه العسكريه
بالكامل وهي سابقه تاريخيه بسبب وجود
هؤلاء ضمن
الشبكات التي اعلن عنها في جهاز القضاء او
جهاز الشرطه
ويتحدث عن اليمنيين هناك الاشتراكات التي
تتداخل عن مواطن الرايه وكلها ايضا محسوب
على هذا الجماعه نتحدث حتى عن الاحزاب
المحافظه يعني تصوري مثلا ان حزب البديل
من اجل المانيا والذي يقال بان ولد وضع
هيئه حمايه الاسطوره باستخبارات الداخليه
وضعت الجناح شبابي منه تحت الرقابه
لمديرته اليمنيه المتطرفه
او احد مؤسسه او جزء كبير بقيادته هم منا
من سلقوا من الاتحاد المسيحي الديناصورات
الحزب المستشاره الالمانيه
المتطرف هي موجوده في عمق المجتمع خصوصا
ان الذاكره الذاكره الالمانيه بعد الحرب
العالميه التي الكثير من الاصوات
الالمانيه
عامه على المانيا
قاده الحلفاء على البلد حتى ان برلين ال
ال ال الجوهره التاريخيه لالمانيا والتي
كانت ايضا عاصمه الرايقه الثالث قبل نهايه
النازيه كان كانت ايضا معرضه وتعرضه
التقسيم بشتى مختلف من من الجدار الى
النظام السياسي الذي كان موجود في غرب
الجدول
شرق وغربلين وغيره الامر هو هو جزء من
ثقافه عامه في البلاد ترى بان البلاد قد
تعرضت كبير وبان الاحتلال الحلفاء لها
قومه مساحتها الجغرافيه لذلك يعتبرون بان
مواطن يعتبرونه حدود الدوله الالمانيه
الحقيقه تاخذ جزء من هولندا ولا يعترفون
ايضا بحدود الدوله الاتحاديه الحديثه التي
تاسست عام 1944 ويقولون بان امتدادات
تمتدي لهذه الدول وهذا الامر لا يخفيه
زعماء التنظيمات الي في المانيا الذين
يرون بان وجود هذا وجود الالماني متسعه
اكثر مما اقره الحلفاء سواء بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه او بعد تاسيس الجمهوريه
ومن نتج عنه من تقسيمات داخل البلاد سواء
المشاركه المانيا او غرب المانيا لذلك هذا
الامر الحقيقه الانتباه لماذا لان الجنوب
الالماني والغرب الالماني الغالي ايضا
الان يتحرك
في الجيوب اليمنى المتطرفه
التي تتحرك فيه جيوب اليمين المتطرفه
هذا الحقيقه هو الذي اشار اليه وزير
الدفاع باننا لتوقع هجوم سوريين مسلحا على
على على الدوله على مؤسسه الدوله السوريه